So now that we are done with the work for Cycle Four let's see what happens in
Cycle Five. Two things will happen in Cycle Five.
One is we are going to try to issue the next instruction. Another thing is,
we're going to try to see if we can dispatch an instruction, write the result,
or comment. Obviously we can issue this instruction so let's do that.
So, the question for you is do we dispatch an instruction. Right here,
which instruction gets dispatched? Leave it empty if none of them gets
dispatched. Another question for you is, do we write any results in this cycle?
If yes, write which instruction gets to write the results. If no, just leave
this empty and obviously we won't be committing any instructions. The name of
the instruction here should be the, really the ROB entry. So if it's for
example the ROB1 instruction that gets dispatched you should write ROB1 here.